[Música]
bien pues quiero dar las gracias a ted
que nos haya invitado a esto para poder
compartir esto que fue mi vida y cómo se
construyó la empresa ya me presentaron
pues entonces bueno quiero decirles que
yo tengo una familia mi esposa me ha
dado la dicha de ser padre de cuatro
maravillosos hijos bien yo vengo de una
familia humilde
mi padre era ferrocarrilero era
jornalero debía es el trabajo más más
duro que hay dentro del ferrocarril
mi madre junto con él lo que me dieron
fueron los sobre todo la cultura del
trabajo la pasión el respeto la humildad
sí y la honradez
pero mi madre tenía una característica
única mi madre apenas apenas sabía poner
su nombre pero era una emprendedora
cuando éramos muy niños de 5 años 6 años
le pedíamos un 20 vaya a la tienda y
ella sabiamente hizo que no lo ganáramos
dice mandó comprar una caja al mercado
de abastos en caja de limones al mercado
de abastos y nos hizo bolsitas y nos
mandó a la calle a venderlos mamá mamá
no me da miedo como que da miedo cabrón
al elevado nos como que no se puede
claro que si se para monos y nos mandaba
pero ella siempre va atrás de nosotros
nos dejaba solos creíamos que si nos
sentíamos superman pero ella siempre iba
atrás de nosotros no lo dijo ya que
estábamos viejos no pero bueno
y después mi madre en la tienda de
perdón saco una mesita para vender
raspados y de ahí hizo una tienda muy
grande dentro de la tienda ella compraba
combustibles que vendían para que se
utilizaban para el boiler los boilers de
leña en aquel tiempo y cuando ella se da
cuenta que eran constituidos por hacer
río y por petróleo dijo pues esto lo
podemos hacer nosotros y ha preparando a
veta la maderería y trae esa cherry ni
petrolia que lo vamos a hacer pues sí
sorteamos la tienda y aparte nos daba
para ir a vender a otras tiendas yo creo
que ahí fue la primera empresa que
y se creó y mi papá me hizo una
carretilla una con madera con tres
tablas y compró para ti de ruedas de
patín y pues andaba yo con mi carreta y
te anime o transporte iba a la maderería
entregaba toda la cosa no hay en la
esquina se juntaba en la esquina de la
tienda se juntaban dos muchachos a echar
cerveza echar música y toda la cosa y me
veían y me decían el tonto lin el tonto
link bien a mis 14 años
me pasó algo me apasioné por el tema del
ciclismo tenía que comprar una bicicleta
de 5 mil pesos no tenía recursos para
hacerlo lo primero que hice fue ir hasta
sonora que donde estaba trabajando mi
papá para pedirle que me diera esos 5
mil pesos tomé el tren porque nos daban
la prestación del ferrocarril llegué
allá mi papá se sorprende dijo
como cómo llegaste o sea estaba yo chico
de papá no se asusten no pasa nada miren
lo que vengo es por esto el tema de la
bicicleta me dijo que no que no tenía
que para comprar eso tenía que trabajar
cuatro o cinco meses me dijo hijo es
tanto que tú no sabes lo que gano me
regresé muy triste pero en el camino
dije como si se puede hacer esto no era
un verano del 77 y pensé hice mi plan
voy a pedirles chamba a tener la
maderería y aparte de mi tiempo libre
voy a hacer combustibles hice una
planeación financiera dije la voy a
hacer y si casi la hice en a finales de
agosto cumplí pero completé cuatro mil
pesos ya mi papá vio dijo bueno ahí te
va si hay debate completo a los siete
meses en un tercer lugar en campeonato
estatal le echa tantas ganas leche
tantas ganas a esto que gane un
campeonato estatal
a mis 17 años entró a trabajar al
ferrocarril mi papá me metió a lo más
bajo me metió a intendencia a ser
barrendero cuando me presento me dicen
hay un viaje a nogales en los trenes
pasajeros que en aquel tiempo había y
que hay que hacer pues barrer los
limpiarlos y viajar hasta allá
atendiendo al pasaje y dije pues vámonos
no tenía 17 años me fui y cuando llegó a
la frontera dije guau nunca había
viajado tan lejos llegué a nogales
sonora y lo primero que hice plantarme
frente a la frontera frente al alambrado
y decir wow eeuu y que no manchen eeuu
tenía 17 años entiéndame por favor y
entonces después de eso empecé a ver que
mis compañeros traían cosas de allá dije
guau guau que el bisne no no pues a
partir de allí a partir de ahí bueno
pues la prepa la saqué estaba en cuarto
semestre la saqué con un promedio con un
promedio con un promedio muy bajo y
bueno
por ahí a mis 19 años a los 19 años en
un viaje y precisamente iba a quien ayer
y en el burrito un tren sube una hermosa
mujer ahí en valle verde diary tetitlán
por ahuacatlán más o menos iba a visitar
una hermana para ni otro pueblo que está
por aquí abajito antes de ruiz
me enamoré de ella le dije la vi dije
esta es no me le declaré así en el viaje
me dijo que no me dijo no a los tres
años a los 22 años me casé con ella y el
próximo enero cumplimos 35 años de
casados señora bonita muchas gracias
ya estaba yo
había entrado a la universidad pero
bueno ya ni siquiera fui porque yo no me
daba con mis viajes con él con todo ya
no me daba entonces ahí está capitán nos
casamos en la capi que en el balneario
que está ahí en entonces
bueno entre las cosas que trae empecé a
traer joyería fantasía y empezó a pegar
entonces me empecé a especializar en eso
lo vendía entre amigos entre conocidos
en familiares tenía un vochito y salía a
vender a diferentes lugares y venir aquí
a tepic aquí tenía muchos clientes allá
en guadalajara yo tenía una clienta que
tenía una empresa como si fuera como de
como de multinivel así tenía muchas
vendedoras y pues pues se quedó y va y
me emociona va a ver la sinergia de la
empresa veía cómo se movía la gente iban
compraban le digo oye como yo me
emocionaba y veía yo quería eso quería
una empresa dije y como twisted en una
empresa y me dice no fernando este pues
tienes que ser un profesional tener una
carrera y tratar y yo por dentro dije
hay cabo yo que dejé la escuela ya no
califico
en su momento pero en cuanto a bajé las
escaleras ya estaban en la calle dije
como chingados algún día voy a tendrá
una empresa así y si me di a la labor de
empezar en eso lo primero que se me
ocurre es un puesto en el mercado del
mercado lo primero que se me ocurrió es
un puesto en el mercado de la colonia
del fresno fue lo que vi y dije oye y si
mejor en el centro se me hacía agua como
decir en el centro se hacía como tener
un local en andares en guadalajara en mi
contexto y en mi tiempo
y dije bueno si consigue el local un
metro cuadrado en el edificio muy verde
bajo una escalera y bueno pues ya tenían
local un local establecido después de
ahí vino una tienda más otra más y otra
más y finalmente cerramos ya con tres
tiendas en la zona de obregón ya
vendiendo ya viajaba y había dejado
obviamente la bicicleta y de que el
ferrocarril ya viajaba a los ángeles en
avión y después volaba hasta nueva york
guau sea ya era otra cosa entonces aquel
reto ya de la empresa ya la tenía entre
mis clientes me decía no ya porque uno
vende bolsas en son guau pues sabía que
donde estaba en los ángeles voy lo busco
y ahí conozco al señor robert chen y
empecé a trabajar con él pues ya tenía
dos giros de fantasía y bolsa a los tres
años el señor robert chin me llama y me
dice fernando te voy a parecer un buen
negocio mochilas
le dije ok va pero yo no sabía ni no
sabía ni de mercado ni de producto ni de
nada de eso pero se la tomé porque mi
intuición me decía que había algo detrás
quizás robert había visto algo detrás de
mí para haberme ofrecido ese negocio sí
me lo dijo después de 20 años sabes que
fernando le pregunta él sí me dice es
que yo veía en ti cosas que no veía en
otros clientes de la ciudad mexica que
aunque me compraban 10 veces más que tú
entonces y éste y me acordé pues si son
los valores que mis padres nos dieron
entonces ya sobre eso pues ya robert hay
logo me dice también es que tú nunca me
pedías crédito
ok y a partir de allí el sí me dio
crédito y en cantidades muy grandes y
muy entonces
una cosa que le tengo mucho
agradecimiento señor rachel es que la
confianza que me dio porque nunca le
firmé un documento a él por todo lo que
él me vende entonces
le tengo muchísima muchísima lealtad al
señor robert chen porque me dio su
confianza y hasta la fecha y jamás le
digo hasta mis hijos aunque me muera no
me lo de fraude por favor señor robert
chin bien ya vendiendo mochilas me me
decían mis clientes porque no le pone
personajes es lo que se vende
pensé en barbie me fui a california
llegué a mattel y les dije mi proyecto
de poner la imagen de barrio y las
mochilas me dijeron que no dijeron que
no me vengo muy triste pero dije pues
vamos a ver como por donde le doy no un
día a mis hijos que eran ir a las
fiestas de octubre en guadalajara y al
llegar y una colono no no una muy larga
pero estaba tan larga porque quien se
estaba presentando era tatiana y las
niñas estaban vestidas todos eh tatiana
dije esta es a los 3 días y estaba en la
ciudad de méxico buscando también en
televisa picando aquí picando allá
finalmente llegué a la oficina de ellos
pues el que me atendió fue el señor
andrés puentes el que era su esposo y
dijo le pareció bien adelante firmamos y
bueno y ahí nació la mochila oficial de
tatiana sí que la promocionaba muchísimo
en la televisión
y bueno después de eso bueno en la
empresa hemos tenido muchísimas
licencias de muchísimos personajes pero
una de las cosas que yo he tenido para
conseguir las cosas es con la operación
de enfado jode y mortifica o sea
estará dale dale y dale un día se me
ocurrió más falda y mi esposo yo
agarramos una maleta con muestra aspira
bar ya buenos aires a buscar aquí no
para firmar con la falda cuando llegara
llegamos no no estaba aquí no estaba su
sobrina julieta colombo y nos dice no no
no no me interesa
a mí me interesa la editorial y no sé
qué no pues nos regresamos a los cuatro
años estamos firmando operación de
enfado después se me ocurre y mario bros
y una empresa muy grande que se llama
nintendo que quizás la conozcan entonces
me fui hace aaron igual con mi maleta
con inglés a medio chile es y me voy
pasearon y bueno pues también me dijeron
que no a los 4 años la tuvimos y así fue
hello con microsoft y bueno
entonces
pues a mí me
me da muchísimo gusto y mucha gente me
pregunta oye tú algún día visualiza
hasta estar allí la verdad es que no
la verdad es que no no no visualicé
estar donde estoy actualmente si
entonces
porque nunca me imaginé que pudiera que
pudiera afirmar con
[Música]
microsoft con nintendo
estar junto con el señor lópez javier
lópez chabelo si nunca me lo imaginé y
bueno pues lo logré sí y como como ha
sido esto o sea como ha sido el
crecimiento como ha sido como lo he
hecho así como les decía del local que
yo me puse en el centro no vaya a la
montaña lo veía como si fuera una
montaña subía allí y al estar arriba yo
veía que había otra más grande y otra y
otra y otra y hasta donde hemos llegado
bueno hace hace poco pues unos tres años
recibimos una llamada de una empresa que
quería hacer una alianza estratégica con
nosotros porque habían visto los bolsos
porque por cierto no solamente son
mochilas también son bolsos entonces los
vieron en el mercado y nos dijeron
fernando queremos que ustedes queremos
hacer una mención con ustedes para que
los bolsos de gareth lleven la marca
barbie wow nos tocaron la puerta hasta
tocar la puerta barbie entonces goretti
mi hija y yo empezamos a desarrollar
producto porque era muy difícil
desarrollar un producto cuando
tradicionalmente barberá para niñas y
ahora teníamos que hacer bolsos de dama
fue muy difícil duramos un año
desarrollando el producto y ya cuando lo
desarrollamos
ya cuando lo tuvimos como cuando tu bebé
no lo ves hermoso lo amas y quieres que
todo el mundo te lo chile bueno pues ya
listos que hacemos pues la planeación
estrategia que quisimos dijimos vamos a
ofrecerle solamente las cadenas
y vamos a ofrecerles a palacio de hierro
y liverpool perfecto muy bien mattel nos
dio un espacio en polanco en una en sus
oficinas preciosas nos dieron un
'showroom' lo arreglamos hermoso que es
la foto donde está goretti por ahí
estamos felices y recibimos por la
mañana a la compradora del palacio llegó
y nos dice papá papá vio los productos y
dice sabes que no no me interesa tu
producto está fuera de línea no es lo
que busco si le quitas la marca barrio
lo mismo nos dijo todo nos sentimos
derrotados céntimos tristes pero vamos a
esperar a liverpool en la tarde a lo
mejor ella
si va a ser nos dijo lo mismo nos dijo
exactamente el mismo este ya estábamos
estamos destrozados salimos de ahí nos
fuimos a un restaurante en polanco donde
en una terraza que frente a la terraza
estaba una tienda de palacio
y mi hija lloro mi hija yo lo perdono
lloró hoy y después de cenar
se levanta y dice papá como chicos que
no se puede claro que si se puede le
vamos a dar vuelta le vamos a dar vuelta
al negocio papá si le vamos a dar vuelta
y va a saber y ahí vamos a estar hoy por
hoy y desde hace algunos años estamos en
todas las cadenas con los bolsos y ya
desde a también diseño estamos con un
palacio entonces lo logramos el gusto
que me dio fue que esa resiliencia que
yo siempre había tenido ya estaba
trascendiendo a mi hija y eso es lo más
grande que puede que me pudo haber
pasado entonces una de las cosas que
tenemos en la empresa y unas cosas que
siempre me he propuesto es ayudar a
nuestros colabores a creer en sí mismos
sí a tener siempre una empresa humana en
donde puedan sentir que están como en
una familia lo que nos ha llevado a ser
una de las mejores empresas para
trabajar en méxico por great place to
work y el año pasado logramos el quinto
lugar y no dudó algún día no dudó algún
día llegará a ser el primer lugar
y bien
yo la verdad es que cuando me dijeron de
de tepic me dio muchísimo gusto y me dio
muchísimo gusto porque aquí nació mi
padre en acaponeta mi esposa es de ese
nayarit y en la empresa ha tenido mucho
talento en nayarit y puedo constatar les
por experiencia propia que en nayarit
hay talento eso sí a mí me ha quedado
claro y irónicamente lo que a mí me ha
motivado que los motivadores que he
tenido en mi vida han sido los no las
humillaciones las burlas el que a veces
me digan que no puedo esos son los
motivadores que me dan que quizás a
ustedes lo a ustedes más de una vez les
ha pasado y cuando les suceda eso
recuerden la frase mágica de mi madre
como chingados que no se puede claro que
sí se puede muchas gracias
vale
[Música]